imagine there was a metal as rare as
gold but it had one magical property it
can be transported over a communication
line like sending physical cash as a
direct message nearly instantly but
Bitcoin isn't a boring gray medal it's a
virtual coin taking the form of a number
at first these Bitcoins had no value at
all they were simply passed around for
fun by people who were interested in the
idea like digital tickets to a fair
which didn't yet exist gradually
hobbyists collected and sold Bitcoins
for a fraction of a penny just to prove
the system could work because once
Bitcoin had any value at all and
therefore a price it became a powerful
social technology this gave birth to a
new layer of Internet marketplaces which
didn't require or even allow traditional
money a New Freedom had emerged Bitcoin
was being used by people who had nothing
to do with its creation and no
government could stop it